E
UR LIFE A LING.
WE WL EXPLAIN INETAI
STRAIG AHEAD
RAPHAEL WARNOCS WIN IN GEORGIA
LA NIGHT DOESN'TEAN 'S
ME TO HA A PITY PAY OR
WHE AND COMPLAIN.
I ARTED OUT IN RADIO AND TO
THSEVEN.
RONALD REAGAN S PRIDENT.
DURI THE PIOD OF TIME
BI CLINTON BECAMPRESENT.BARACK .
NOW WE'VE GOJOEY
THERE'S UPAND DOWNS ON
POLICAL CLES.FIT THERE'S GOODGO.
WINNG THE HOES HUGE, ASREPUBLICO
GOVE WITH THE SAMEAJORYTHAT PELE
POWER OF SUBPOEN THAT MEANS IF
TH HOLD TOTHER, A G "I"
I GUESS, THE ALITYO HOLD
BIDEN ACCOUNBLE  THE BOR BIG TE,
WILLLL BE INVESTIGED RHTLY
SO.
'S BEEN LONG ORDUE
FIT WE DO NEED TO AS AND
LOOKT THIS OBJECTILY.WHAT DID L?
WHATOULDE LEARN FROM I
IFOU ARE A FOOALL AM AA SIDELI E
COACH, WHAYOU ING TOALKABOUT WI?
WELL, VE GOT TO FIGU OUT HTO STS
GA, HOW TOET T OFFENSE
MOVING HE MAKE ADJUSTMTS
COME O AND HE A TTER
SECOND HALF.
THE MIDTERCYCLE QUOTEDHAT
TELLS?TIME FORHE PLIC TO STARTPN
D EMACING THE VOTI SYSTEM
THAT WE VE ANDOT THE ONE
THEY SAID TH HAD
THEY ARE COMNOT  THEY WANTEMO B,
AFTER EY WINTATELEGISLATES, AN N
CHANGE LOSOVER TE, AT L
THE TEGRITY MEASUR F
ELECTIONS AT TY WANT, ANDPUT ITR
ELTIONS.THAT MEA THEY NEED TO AY
WH IS E EARLY VOTINGAME,
THE LLET AT HARVESNG GE.
EY NEED TO DO LL,  NOT
BETT THAN THE DEMOATS, ALL
GALLY.
I LL EXPLAIN THA
TH CAN START OUT EVEELECTIONAY F
THOUNDS  VOTES.
IT WAS ESTATEDAST YESTERDAY
WHEN VOTINSTARTED IN GEOIA
THAT HSCHEWALKER, BECAUS
EAY VONG, MAIL-IN VONG I
GEORGIA, HE WE INT
YEERDAY'S ECTI DN
200,0 TO 250,000 VOT.
THAT INSANE.
ERE IS A RUCTANCE ON THE
RESISTANCEF REBLICANS TO
VOTE BMAILR TE EARLYO IF
YOU TAKE ATEP CK AND YOUTAKE A E
STEM CURRENTLY STAND THERE
ARE CURRENY 15 STATES AND
WASHINGTON, D.THEY DON EVEN VE .
LAWS.
KEY ATESIKE PENNLVANIA,
NEVA, NEW YO, NEW JEEY.
TH THE'S DOZENOFTATES
THAT HAVE SOORM  LEGIZED
BALLOT HARVESTG MEETING THAT
ANTHIRPARTY CAN COME A
PICK UP UR BLOT FOR YOSTATES LIA
D HERS, THEY SENOUT
BAOT TO EVERY TER ON THEIR
VOTEROLLS WHETHER EY RUEST
ONE OR NOT.THISS A SYST.
THE CURRENT REITY.
I THINK IS THE BE SYSTEM?
NO, I THINK 'S BAD.
MOCRATS HAVE ERACED TH
STEM.
REBLICANS HAVE NOT COME TO
THEIR OWN TRIMENT.
THEY IGNORE THEALI.
LO, I'VE BEEN VE CLEAR.
MY WORLD, IN A
HAITY-PERFECWORL IF I LAID
OUT WHAT WE HAVE THE MOST
INTEGRY ANEVERYBODWOULD
HAVE CONFIDEE INHE RESTING
ELTIONS, OWNER RUBLINS WIN
GURNATORIAL RACES ANSTATE
LEGISLATURESI WOMAKE
ELECON D NATIONAL HOLIY.
I WOD HAVEAPER BALLOTS OY.
I WOD HAVE PARTISAN OBSERVERS,
PEOPLE FROEVERY RTY.THEY WOULD N
EVERY ECIN IN THE VOTE
UNTI AFTER THE POLLOSE
UP CLO AND PSONA
EVERY STE SHOULD REQUI
SIGNATURE RIFICATION, VOR
I.D., CHAIN  CUSTODYONTRS,
UPDAD VOTER ROLLBUT KE I
SA, RIT NOW  NEETO WK
THIN THE SYSTEM AS IT EXTS
BECAUSE MOCRS ARE PLAYING AVERYN
ELECTI DAY IN THE DA LEADING
TO ELECTIONAY TN
PUBLICANS AR
DECRATS ARE NOT  INTERESD
IN THE QUALITYF A CANDIDE ORHOLG
VOTERS OR SSINBABIES OR
SHAKING HANDS OR GOING TO FARES.
DEMOCRATS ARHIDI, AVOIDING
DEBAS, AVOING EIR ADORING
MEA FANS.
TH AREAISING HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF LLARAND USING
THOSE ON NEGATIVADS AGAINST
REPUBLICANS ANMOSTMPORTANTLYTHE"
EY A PLANG A BALLOT ME.
DEMOATS E ONLY IERESTED IN
GETTING THEIR HANDS  ENOUGBALLOL
PUT THEM OR THTOP TO WINELECTIO.
AT MEANS BIG BALLOT RVESTING
OPERIONS, THATEETS THEGG
EARLVOTI NUMBERS
BIG MAIL-IN BAOTS R
DEMOCRS.A HUGE DADVANTAGE FOR
REPUBLICANS.
IT'S OBVIO.
YESTERDAY'S GRT CA IPOINT,HERSC0
VOTES BEFOREHE D EVEN
STARTED.
LOOK AT IS NEW PCE FROM
AXIOS LAYI OUTOW TUSANDS
OFEORGIANS WERE ID TO BRINUP WAM
TO VOTFOR E FAR LEFT
SENATOR.
THE TAIC IS NOTI RATIOL
ORGANIZINGSED BY DEMOCRAACROSS .
ITNOTHER EXALE OHOW
REPUBLICANS E NOT ONLY PYING
CATCH UP, TH AREUNNING
ELECT,
IMINE IS IS MY iPHONE 1.VERSIONS
ER HERE HA A 10.0 RSION OF
ECTIONS ANREPUBLICANS NE
TO CAT UP AND BUILD OUA
14-POI ELEION DEL.
PUBLICANS CAN'JUST ACCEPTTHEY'R.
IT'S N GOING TWORK.TOO STEEP OF.
E G.P. CAN'T JUST TALL
SEEDARLY VOTING, MAIIN
VONG TO DECRATS ANPUT
THEMSELVES IO ONDEEP
HO AFTER ANOTHER
LOOK AT FLIDA.
ERE VOTING SYSM WAA
COMPLE.
THE 20 ELEIONS, HANGIN
SWINGING, NTED, PERFATED
CHS ETETERA, ET CETE.
THEY FIXED THAT SYST APPRED
OUTHINK ANYBODY N EV SAYWITH COY
537 TES THE WATHE IN THAT
RACEUT AT SOME PNT, THE
PREME COURT WAED A THAT
WAS THE END HAT.
W THEY FIX TIR SYSTEM, THEY
PUT INTEITY MEASURES ITHE
SYST.
ORIDHAS ONOF T BEST RUNVOTING SY
AND BY THE WAYEPUBCANS INFLORIDD
VOTINGARLY
REPUBLICANS IN FLODA, THEYHAVE .
EVERY VOTER S TO HAVE VOTER
I., SIATURE VACATION IS
REQUIRED.
WHATEV THEEMOCRATS AREOING
WI THE EARLY VING,HE
PUBLANS NEED TOT AS
MATCH  IN ESE OTSTATES.
ME CAS REPLICANS DO NEED
BETTER CANDATES.
I'LL GIVYOU E EXAMPLE.NOT TO PKA
GUBERNATORL CANDIDATE DO
MAER OUT OF WHATOU LOOK AT
HIS POSITI ON ORTIONHE HAD
NOXCEPTIONS FOR RAPE, INCEST,
THE MOTH'S LIFE.
IN PENNSYLVAA, POLICALLY,NOT MON
PESYLVIA WITH AT PITIO
IT'S SIMY MAEMATICALLYIMPOSSIB.
FBI CAIDATFOR THAT RACE AND
IT H IMPT ON THE ENTIRREBLICAN .
I VE CONFIDENCE THAT WITH THE
RIGHLEADSHIP, REPUBLICS
N GET TH DON
THESSWING ATES IN 2024.
'S N EASY T IT IDOAB.
ALSO REMEMR THOSE OTHER JOR
PART TO ALL OF THII THINK I'M TG
ABOUT IT.
I CALL IT ACCELERATED GRATN.
AT REFERS TO REPUBLICANSEDUPITHD
BLUETATES AND SEEKING REFUGE
IN STATES KE FLODA,
CARONAS, TEXAS.
NNESSEE, ET TERA
TH'RE SICK OF HI TAX, HIGHCOSTSE
REAUCRACY.THEY DON'T LIKHIGH CR.
THRETU OF SCHOOLS BEG SHUT
DOWN, COVID MAATES BNG
SHOVED DOWN THR THAT
EY WANT IN SCHLEARNING FOR
THEIR KI.
EY WT A BETTUALITY OF
LIFE.
THEY WANT  KP MORE OF THEIR
HARD-EARNEMONEAND BYHE
WA THEY WOULD PREFERHE
WARMER WEAER ESPECIALLY TH
MORE AND MORBABYOOMERS THAT
ARE RERING.
THEY ARE N MOVING IN DROVETO
AD STAS.
LOOK AT YO SCREEN,HE UAUL
INX.
COSTS NEARLY REE MES ASMUCH TG.
OK ATHAT.FOR GRAN.
U WA TO GO FROM
GRANT.CIO TO DALLAS?
YOU WANT TO  FRODALLAS TOSAN FRG
U-HAUL A FAVOR.1400 BUCKS
THAT SAKS VOLUMES.
ANYWAY, AMERANS E VOTING
WITH THEIREET SANCFIED
TO FLED R LEFT STAS DA
AFR DAAND THE PEOPLEHAT
TE TO BE LEANG IN A LOT OF
THE STES ARE CONSERVIVE.
A LOT OF PPLE E MOVING TO
ORID
TH HAVE ABOUT 80NEW
RESIDENTS A Y.
IT'S GREAT, E WEHER IS
EAT,HE ECONOMY GRO, TH
PRPERITY IS THER
E STATE GETS SONGER ANDSTRONGER,
W JERSEY, CALIRNIAEAKER.
GUS WHAT.
THATEANS THOSETATEHAVE
LESSONSERVATIVE.
AT DS AT MEAN FOR A
PRESIDENTIALLECTN AR
QUESTION LE TH MEANS SOATES THA.
TH HAVSTATES LIKE NEDA AND
ARIZONA, SLY F THEM THEY ARE
DOINWELLN TERMS OFPOPULATION IN.
WEVEA LOT OF THOSEEOPLE
FROM CALORNIAND THE VAST
MAJORITY OF EM HAPPENETO B
LIBERATHEY TEND TOE MOREEFT WING
SO IMAKES THE STES EVENHARDER T.
TH MAY ALL SEEM RY
COMPLICATEAND 'SOING TO
KE DELIBERATE ANWELL THOUGHT
OUT STRATEGY A IT'WHY
REPUBLICANNEEDO HAVE A SENSE
OF URGENCY NOW.
BERE THE ELEION IN
NOVEMBER 202SPECL VICTIMS
THE ISSUOF PERCTING THE
GROUNDAME, PERFEING
BALL GAMMBRANG EARLY
TING AND MAIL-IN VOTINAND
LEL BALLOT HARSTINAND